bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la force centrifuge dans l'univers
les objets sont soumis à des forces une
force est une action sur l'objet qui va
entraîner un changement de vitesse par
exemple lorsqu'on lance une pomme vers
le haut avec une certaine vitesse la
force de gravité exercée par la terre va
changer la vitesse de la pomme en la
tirant vers le bas jusqu'à ce qu'elle
retombe au sol ainsi si aucune force ne
s'applique à un objet alors la vitesse
et la direction de cet objet vont rester
constante il va se diriger en ligne
droite
toujours dans la même direction et à la
même vitesse ceci s'applique également
si les différentes forces exercées sur
l'objet ce qu'on pense comme dans le cas
d'un palet de hockey sur glace
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe
d'inertie imaginons maintenant que l'on
se trouve très loin de la terre dans une
région de l'espace aucune force n'ai
ressenti
si on lance une pomme par le principe
d'inertie
étant donné qu'aucune force ne
s'applique elle continuera sa
trajectoire à la même vitesse et dans la
même direction
maintenant imaginons que l'on place
cette pomme dans une grande roue de
forme circulaire et que l'on fasse
tourner la roue lançons maintenant la
pomme dans la roue au départ elle va se
diriger en ligne droite et à vitesse
constante car aucune force ne s'applique
sur elle mais au moment où elle
rencontre le bord de la route la
paroisse va repousser la paume vers
l'intérieur exerçant ainsi une force qui
va dévier la trajectoire de la pomme
l'obligeant à terme à suivre la rotation
de la roue
cette force ce qui pousse constamment la
paume vers l'intérieur de la roue est
appelée force centripète c'est cette
force qu'exerce la paroisse sur la pomme
obligeant celle ci a dévié de sa
trajectoire linéaire pour décrire un
cercle
maintenant imaginons que l'on remplace
la pomme par un être humain que l'on va
appeler à pour cette personne
la roue ne semble pas tourner car en
réalité elle est la route on exactement
en même temps
regardons alors ce qu'il se passe si à
donne une impulsion avec ses jambes pour
se projeter vers le haut comme ci
s'apprêtait à sauter
d'un point de vue externe comme aucune
force ne s'applique à va continuer sa
trajectoire en ligne droite en haut que
la roue tourne autour de lui cependant
de son point de vue tout se passe comme
si une force l'attirer vers l'extérieur
en le poussant à retomber sur la paroi
de la roue comme pourrait le faire la
gravité sur terre ainsi bien qu'en
réalité aucune force ne s'applique sur à
il a l'impression de ressentir une force
fictive qui serait dirigé vers
l'extérieur de la roue c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet centrifuge dans cet
exemple
l'intensité de la force centrifuge est
relativement faible cependant si on
augmente le rayon de la roue ou que l'on
augmente sa vitesse de rotation alors
cette force centrifuge devient plus
importante
or si l'on atteint une vitesse de
rotation est à rayons de la roue
suffisamment important cette attraction
vers l'extérieur pourra se rapprocher de
celle ressentie par une personne à la
surface de la terre
c'est ce qu'on appelle la gravité
artificiel de cette façon on pourrait
reproduire la gravité à laquelle nous
sommes habitués sur terre dans un
habitat en rotation qui serait située
quelque part où aucune force ne
s'applique ou encore en orbite autour
d'une planète et donc en apesanteur
par ailleurs c'est également grâce à cet
effet centrifuge que l'on peut mettre
des objets en orbite autour de la terre
par exemple sans qu'il ne s'en rapproche
jamais en effet ils sont attirés par la
gravité vers le centre de la terre mais
l'effet centrifuges qui est générée par
l'inertie compense cette attraction et
les forcent à suivre une trajectoire
circulaire
enfin si l'on suppose que l'on réussisse
un jour à construire une centrifugeuse
qui serait apte à générer une telle
gravité artificiel l'effet ressenti par
une personne dans cet habitacle ne
serait pas exactement le même que celui
ressenti sur terre en effet cette force
centrifuge n'existe pas réellement et
découle de l'inertie des objets dans un
référentiel en rotation or dans cette
situation l'effet centrifuge n'est pas
le seul à s'appliquer en l'occurrence si
la personne dans la centrifugeuse
l'achète une pomme la pomme ne tomberait
pas à ses pieds comme elle l'aurait fait
sur terre mais légèrement en arrière
ceci est dû au fait que la pomme au
moment d'être lâché se trouve plus
proche du centre de la centrifugeuse et
se déplace donc moins vite on appelle
cet effet les faits coriolis et c'est
lui qui est à la base de beaucoup de
phénomènes comme par exemple le fait que
les cyclones tourner dans un sens dans
l'hémisphère nord et dans l'autre sens
dans l'hémisphère sud